This video was made possible by Curiosity
Stream.
When you sign up at CuriosityStream.com/Wendover,
you’ll also get access to Nebula—the streaming
video platform that Wendover is a part of.
I need not tell you what happened in March,
2020.
Whether you’re watching this now or far
in the future, that date will forever remain
in people’s minds as when the century’s
first pandemic emerged.
It will remain in people’s mind’s as when
the era of social distancing and isolation
began.
It will remain in people’s minds as when
they got sick, or when a loved one got sick,
or worse.
In addition, though, for the millions of people
worldwide working in the aviation industry,
March 2020 will mark the date when they lost
their jobs, when their company started turning
south.
It will mark the beginning of the end.
There is perhaps no industry more severely
impacted by COVID-19 than aviation.
As it is a brand new virus, in these early
days, when there is no immunity or vaccines,
the only way to stop or slow its spread is
through physically isolating people.
That is intrinsically in opposition to what
aviation is—aviation works to bring people
together.
That meant that one of the first measures
governments implemented to slow the spread
was to ban travel.
When the virus first emerged, its transmission
primary occurred in China, with only isolated
cases elsewhere from those who had travelled
from the epicenter.
For this issue, the solution was simple—ban
travel from China.
A number of countries, notably including the
US, barred foreigners who had recently been
in China from entering their borders and,
in response to the sharp decline in demand,
a number of airlines cancelled their flights
to greater China.
The financial implications of this were limited
as few foreign airlines are significantly
exposed to China—partly due to the strength
of the Chinese airlines.
Most of those mainland Chinese airlines, meanwhile,
are government-owned so they could take the
hit.
Of course nearby Asian airlines like Scoot,
Cathay Pacific, and ANA would struggle, but
the lockdown of China was more or less a weatherable
hit.
But then the virus spread: first to South
Korea, so airlines cancelled flights to South
Korea, then to Iran, so airlines cancelled
flights to Iran, then to Italy, so airlines
cancelled flights to Italy, but then it seeped
through Italy porous borders to take hold
of the entirety of Europe.
That was the moment when, to airlines, the
situation became severe.
Europe is home to, by revenue, three of the
world’s six largest airlines—the Lufthansa
Group, Air France/KLM, and IAG.
To have a virus devastating their home territory
was an untenable situation—nobody wants
to travel to the center of a Pandemic.
But soon, the untenable situation became worse.
On Wednesday March 11th, televisions switched
on to the American president sitting behind
his desk in the Oval Office.
A speech in this setting is reserved for only
the most solemn occasions.
Only four such addresses occurred in the entire
2010s decade.
The president laid out some steps in his administration’s
response to the virus, the most stunning of
which being a complete ban on all foreign
travelers from Europe.
That was unprecedented.
Europe and the US are two of the most culturally
and economically linked regions in the world
and never before would anyone even imagine
anything even close to a complete travel ban
between the two.
The amount of individuals this would impact
was astronomical.
The North Atlantic is home to one of the busiest
flows of long-haul flights in the world.
More than 1,700 aircraft per day cross the
Atlantic—many of those enormous wide-body
jets.
These are some of the most profitable flights
for airlines out there.
To imagine that this would all just come to
a stop was unthinkable.
Now, Delta, American, and United would join
the big European three to have their demand
slashed by the virus.
All six of the world’s largest airlines,
by revenue, went into crisis mode.
Beyond just the transatlantic flying, intra-Europe
and US domestic traffic figures dropped off
a cliff.
As one example, United Airlines, the fourth
largest airline in the world, issued a press
release announcing a 60% reduction in their
flight capacity in April, 2020.
Even with those drastic cuts, they predicted
an average load-factor—how full their planes
are—of 20-30%.
Since then, they’ve cut flights even further.
Most every airline in Europe started experiencing
net-negative bookings.
That means that they were refunding more bookings
than they had coming in.
Some airlines, including Qantas, Virgin Australia,
WestJet, and more decided to cancel all but
their domestic flights.
Other airlines, including LOT, Brussels Airlines,
and Austrian Airlines decided to just completely
close down for a few weeks or months.
They would fly no flights at all.
Since its occurrence, 9/11 has been the defining
crisis for the aviation industry.
Since civil aviation began, traffic numbers
just grew and grew and grew until suddenly,
on a sunny September morning, that all stopped.
It was bad, and airlines did go bankrupt,
but overall, the industry eventually made
it out the other end.
Less than a week after Coronavirus became
a Pandemic, though, one thing became abundantly
clear to airlines—Coronavirus, to them,
financially, was worse than 9/11.
This was the most severe drop-off in passenger
demand in the history of aviation.
Airlines are no strangers to doing things
that lose money.
There is perhaps no industry out there that
so robustly embraces the idea of a loss-leader
than aviation.
Airlines will go to great lengths to retain
loyalty—both of individual travelers and
of their corporate contracts.
For example, airlines can and often do keep
routes flying in the depths of winter, when
traffic is the lowest, in order to reliably
present themselves as the go-to airline for
their customers.
If, say, there’s a US-based company with
significant amounts of travel to Barcelona,
they’re only going to set up a corporate
contract with an airline that can fly their
employees there year-round.
Therefore, American Airlines, for example,
might fly there for twelve months a year even
if only eight of those turn a profit.
That’s because, with the loss of corporate
contracts, they might only turn a profit flying
to Barcelona five months a year, so overall
yearly profit will be higher by taking a loss
four months a year.
The equation changes when nobody, including
those corporate customers, wants to travel,
though.
Therefore, with the Coronavirus reaching pandemic
level in one of the lowest-traffic periods
of the year, airlines quickly were able to
make the decision to cut loss-leading long-haul
flights.
These cuts are deep.
The Lufthansa group, for example, the seventh
largest airline in the world by passengers,
is reducing its long-haul schedule to a sole
flight from Zurich to Newark, then flights
from Frankfurt to Sao Paulo, Newark, Chicago,
Montreal, Tokyo, Bangkok, and Johannesburg.
To think that this is what the seventh largest
airline in the world in 2020 looks like is
unimaginable, but the situation at the world’s
largest airline, American Airlines, is even
more severe.
This is their long-haul network during the
Coronavirus.
They’ll fly just Miami to London, Dallas
to London, and Dallas to Tokyo.
This is a situation without a lot of good
news.
Jobs will be lost and airlines will go bankrupt,
but there is plenty of hope that the industry
can survive.
While this fall will be far, airlines do have
further to fall than after 9/11.
In 1999, United, American, and Delta achieved
operating margins—the ratio of their earnings
to revenues—of 6.8, 6.5, and 12.7 percent,
respectively.
In 2019, those margins were 9.9, 6.6, and
14.0 percent.
These are small differences, but a few percentage
points can mean the difference between life
and death for an airline.
Another saving grace for airlines is the recent
plummet in oil prices.
This is the byproduct of a price war going
on between two of the world’s largest oil
producers—Saudi Arabia and Russia.
The two countries had long worked together
to limit output based on demand and therefore
more or less control oil prices, but, after
Russia refused to reduce their output, Saudi
Arabia responded by slashing prices and increasing
production in order to price Russia out of
the market.
Therefore, the same barrel of jet fuel that
would have cost airlines $60 in February costs
only $40 in March, 2020.
That’s a significant discount on airlines’
biggest cost and, if it were not for the biggest
drop in demand in the history of aviation,
they would be celebrating a huge increase
in profits.
In the midst of the crisis, though, they’re
taking the small win of smaller losses.
The aviation industry, as a whole, never truly
recovered from the effects of 9/11.
That’s because “recovery” implies getting
back to normal, and that’s something that
never happened after 9/11, and certainly will
never happen after Coronavirus.
It’s nearly impossible to predict what will
happen in the aftermath of a situation never
seen before.
As we’ve seen already and will certainly
continue to see, the response to extraordinary
circumstances is extraordinary measures.
Therefore, the industry will emerge from the
other end something completely new and novel.
How deep the dip sinks will be determined
by how high the curve soars and that will
be determined by world governments, organizations,
and more than all, how every individual out
there responds to COVID-19.
For those of you subscribed to Nebula, a brand
new original called “Money,” made by the
fantastic YouTuber Tom Scott, just released.
I, along with Sophie Ward, Mike Boyd, Mia
Mulder, and Rohin Francis were subjected to
five of Tom’s games in order to win real
money.
This was an enormous amount of fun to participate
in and it’s just as fun to watch, which
you can do exclusively on Nebula.
The best way to get access to Nebula, of course,
is by subscribing to Curiosity Stream—home
to thousands of fantastic documentaries and
non-fiction shows.
That’s because Curiosity Stream offers a
bundle deal with Nebula so that you get access
to both streaming sites for just $20 a year
at CuriosityStream.com/Wendover.
That’s truly the best deal in streaming,
especially considering that on Nebula, in
addition to my, Tom Scott’s, and everyone
else’s originals, you can watch all Wendover
and Half as Interesting videos completely
ad free.
Once again, that bundle deal is available
at CuriosityStream.com/Wendover, and by signing
up, you’ll be supporting Wendover Productions
and plenty of other independent educational
creators.